depuis trois ans marie claire un
handicap mais il ne se voit pas à la
suite d'un traumatisme crânien elle a dû
réapprendre les gestes du quotidien
aujourd'hui elle a fait le déplacement
au colloque en diversité à l'iut de
vélizy pour tester bcap un logiciel
permettant d'analyser sa conduite
automobile
c'est amusant a testé sur des machines
et à changea d'évaluation
un vécu réel
salaire
cette étrange affaire même très bien à
n'importe qui même en est en tout cas
permis diplôme c'est pourtant selon
l'insee sur les 12 millions de français
handicapés 80% à handicap invisible
comme marie claire organisée par
l'université paris saclay cet événement
avait pour but de montrer le handicap
comme vecteur d'innovation technologique
prendre en compte le handicap en amont
permet de faire des produits beaucoup
plus innovant est bien plus intéressante
pour tous on a tous un jour ou l'autre
besoin d'une assistance donc autant y
penser en amont alors essentiellement
s'adresse aux chercheurs aux
entrepreneurs à tous ceux qui ont envie
de développer des projets qui permettent
d'avoir une société ouverte à tous c'est
s'ouvrir à un marché extrêmement grand
dans lequel tout le monde peut se
retrouver ou donc il ya effectivement
des potentiels à créer applications pour
personnes malvoyantes ou simulateur de
fauteuils roulants
une vingtaine d'ingénieurs ont présenté
leur projet avec démonstrations celui ci
est encore utilisée dans plusieurs
optiques d'abord dans une petite de
sensibilisation en fait dans une optique
d'apprentissage pour les personnes qui
ont récemment handicapés puis tout
simplement pour
les architectes pour pouvoir vérifier
l'accessibilité de certains lieux
publics en fauteuil roulant la majorité
des projets présentés sont encore en
phase de test avant leur entrée sur le
marché en 2015 l'insee estimait que 50 %
des français sont ou seront confrontés
au handicap pour eux mêmes ou pour un de
leurs proches